having pushed the European Union for a
revised Briggs Adil Boris Johnson
finally got what he wanted in Brussels
he said the new agreement was in
everyone's interests what a stress that
this is a great deal for our country for
the UK I also believe it's a very good
deal for our friends in the EU and what
it means is that we in the UK can come
out of the EU as one United Kingdom
England Scotland Wales Northern Ireland
together the last-minute deal was
welcomed by EU leaders it came after
days of intensive negotiations between
UK and EU officials the key change in
comparison is the earlier version of the
deal as Prime Minister Johnson's
acceptance to have customs checks at the
points of entry into Northern Ireland
this compromise will allow will allow us
to avoid border checks between Ireland
and Ireland and will ensure the
integrity of the single market the Irish
Prime Minister welcomed the deal but
some anti brexit campaigners in Brussels
were unconvinced and said they still
face uncertainty I wasn't able to go
back to UK with my husband she live in
case my parents needed more help because
the EU still has to ratify the deal but
the sense here in Brussels is that their
work is done
that's however is not the case for Boris
Johnson he still has to convince the UK
Parliament to back his agreement but
that won't be easy
the deal has failed to win the key
support of the Democratic Unionist Party
or DUP the Northern Irish party that
props up Johnson's Conservative
government it's obviously not a deal we
can support we've made that assessment
on the deal itself we're not doing a
compare and contrast but certainly this
gives us a border in the Irish Sea in
terms of that in terms of customs and in
terms of single market rules without any
consent that is meaningful for the
people of Northern Ireland if the
British prime minister fails to win
parliamentary backing for his
deal he'll be legally obliged to seek an
extension from Brussels to the October
31st brexit deadline but his office says
that is not going to happen
Breck said it would seem is far from
over Natasha butler al jazeera Brussels